the fire inside the cave might not be
the best idea because hey it melts all
the snow and then drips onto your fire
and then your fire goes out and then the
smoke would probably smoke you out but
fire as a light source amazing look at
that shot hey gq i'm jimmy chin and this
is the breakdown
[Music]
[Applause]
127 hours
this is clearly a very critical moment
and seen in the film as aaron
ralston falls into the
canyon and i know aaron was there um
consulting on this so trying to make it
as
accurate depiction of what happened to
him i'm sure for danny the director this
you know how do we establish what
happens to him like really give a sense
to people like what actually happened
how he fell
what's going on
the pacing of the scene is really cool
there's this principle action when he
takes the fall they show his
you know a cutaway of this totally
different you know item his headphones
like falling slow motion onto the ground
and then you really get a view of
without having to describe it what
happens
and that's hard to do you know without
someone actually saying it and really
making it feel like okay this is real i
love the moments when he looks up in the
sky it's like this this one scene is
like paced
it's got a lot of
different
kind of um
really cool pacing in it then it's quiet
really trying to get into the
head of of aaron here and or at least in
the real character of aaron but
of what it must be like to kind of
realize in this moment you're
trapped and like taking in his
environment like he's assessing where he
is and those shots kind of
get into the character's head like oh
where am i
basically establishing i'm trapped in
this place they have a lot of different
camera angles like there's a top-down
shot that's like really cool and
establishes like he's in this narrow
passageway there's some shots just like
real close up on his arm to really show
how it's wedged in there and then it
shows this point of view you know as he
looks up to the sky all of that a
storyboarded out to really establish
like what happens here and i think they
do a really wonderful job here the
revenant
[Music]
the fire inside the cave might not be
the best idea because hey it melts all
the snow and then drips onto your fire
and then your fire goes out and then the
smoke would probably smoke you out but
fire as a light source amazing look at
that shot i'm not sure if they had any
other light sources in the shot of the
cave but it draws the eye
to this little cave it gives you a real
sense of the setting and the scale of
the place and the landscape and
clearly shows he's he's just trying to
survive the night often times
the best ways to survive are not
necessarily uh the greatest um for
cinematographers i deal with that a lot
where you're like oh
we're on the side of a mountain and i'm
shooting you're like this shot would be
absolutely mind-blowing if they were a
little further out on that ridge and
profiled against the sky and that's not
um
usually uh something i can suggest
because you're in the middle of a climb
the best shots are shots that you
wouldn't normally see just standing at
eye level you know like that's what we
all see all the time and so
with the camera you can kind of you're
really looking for a shot that brings
the audience into the moment and
you know if you want to get creative
like moving the camera somewhere other
than like the normal eye level like
you're trying to find shots that are low
that give a different perspective than
you normally see
i'm kind of a believer in in creating
shots that don't necessarily draw
attention to a shot you really want to
have the shot be in service of the story
and the moment and the film
[Music]
using you know what i i think is a great
technique which is
getting in really tight feeling really
intimate with leo you know in that
moment but then also doing these huge
big expansive shots to give you a sense
of scale in the environment he's in just
overall stunning shooting in
these kinds of environments where it's
very very cold extremely tough on crews
you know because you're not just dealing
with
you know managing you know
the
personnel and the crew and and their
safety and equipment
you know in this kind of environment is
really hard to manage oftentimes
you know you have to keep the batteries
warm because they
they completely
deplete when when they get really cold
so you're constantly carrying batteries
either on yourself like in your pockets
sometimes we'll tape hand warmers around
the batteries to try to keep them warm
there's just a lot of considerations in
terms of how to prep your cameras how to
prep your crew
i know
from what i've heard and read you know
that this was
an extremely difficult shoe i did run
into um the director uh
in iraq at one point and he told me that
he watched
meru and showed meru to his crew
referencing meru that this is really
hard filming conditions um maybe shaming
them into thinking that their conditions
weren't as hard but
that's what he told me it's amazing how
much of your life is spent either
especially in these cold environments
melting snow and ice for water and like
moving solar panels to follow the sun
when there's sun if there's sun
battery power is like this constant
issue uh out out in the field when
you're on remote expedition shoots i
don't think um
they had that problem on the revenant
though because i think they had other
resources and opportunities to charge
their batteries
into the wild
[Laughter]
funny enough i i actually climbed
kilimanjaro with emile hirsch
spent a few weeks with him
if this was storyboarded out for the dp
a lot of the conversation would also be
okay how are we going to get each of
these shots we're going to block it out
but really what's most important to me
is like the intention of this scene this
is the nuts and bolts of like what we
need to establish experiencing the
isolation with this character being out
there um he has kind of a moment of
levity in the scene i feel like you're
kind of you're you're experiencing the
the landscape and being isolated in this
huge place
you kind of move inward as the character
moves inward
and then it
finishes with him kind of like stepping
out and then like being back in this
amazing wilderness and it's this shot of
like absolute awe and beauty
and it just ties up that scene so
perfectly the beauty of shooting up
north in alaska in like the spring is
that
the days start to get really long
but the sun stays really low on the
horizon so you have like a lot of really
good shooting hours and beautiful light
for a good part of the day
you know the worst light
then the most challenging light to shoot
in is especially when you're just using
natural light is when the sun's straight
above you and it's just like
you know everybody's eyes are black
because the
contrast of it's just bad light you
never really want to shoot in that but
when you're when you're shooting
outdoors
in these kind of environments you're
often relegated to what's available and
the best light during the days are in
the morning and in the evening this is
really beautiful kind of saturated
probably sunset or
maybe sunrise
shots you know looks like there's a
little cloud cover
but enough for light to get through so
everything's kind of painted with this
like very really saturated colors that's
kind of
the light that you you
you know always aim for or dream of on
expedition shoots you don't have the
luxury of like getting things set up and
facing the right way for the best light
and you kind of have to make do with
what you have when we were shooting with
alex on free solo let's say for instance
he couldn't climb el cap in the light
because it'd be
a lot less friction it's you're hot it
was always challenging because he would
be climbing in this really shady wall
and then the the ground below would be
like really really bright hot light and
so every time you're framing a shot
you're trying to like deal with this
huge
range of of dynamic range of light you
know blasted out blown out mid-day light
on this like
you know
really bright
ground below and then this really dark
shady wall that's always kind of a
challenge indiana jones and the last
crusade
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm often thinking about angles and how
how to shoot something to to tell the
story a bunch of the earlier shots in
here you know shot from the ground kind
of looking up and whenever you have like
these shots looking up you really
make the the characters you give them a
certain amount of weight because you
know like if you're shooting
portraitures it's the same thing it's
like shooting them straight on is one
look but when you when you dip below the
eyeliner and you you place someone up
high it's like visually putting them on
a pedestal right so you can portray
people a certain way just by the angle
of how you shoot them in this case this
shot from above that really establishes
that's kind of cool there's some
foreground elements
the people are framed perfectly there's
these kind of like leading lines that
draw your eye
into where these main
protagonists are
and then you have like this perfectly
lit monument there is a lot of contrast
i think they wanted the light on on the
main monument that they see there that
can be really challenging um is figuring
out like okay well how are we going to
shoot this
what time of day are we going to shoot
this this is the only time it's going to
get light
but it's going to be extremely contrasty
and then oftentimes what happens is like
okay you kind of establish like which
things you're going to prioritize as
getting this light during the day
and then you kind of lean into
whatever you're you're given so you know
when they come through the canyon there
um it's kind of shady it is dramatic you
know they they come out of the the shade
into the light and it's kind of like
this moment when they come into the
light figuratively and and actually
physically
you know discovering this spot and then
if i was looking at this through an
expedition
mindset i i start looking at the walls
on either side of that monument and they
look like there's there's probably some
pretty good climbing there too lord of
the rings return of the king
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you're in a helicopter shooting a
shot like this it's not just the
camera person especially one with this
big of a move
the aerial dp
um
is
making calls on the radio with the pilot
as well and they're probably
sitting together or at least dp sitting
in the back seat of the helicopter being
like okay crab left crab left grab left
and it just means that the helicopter is
kind of crabbing like rotating around
this thing and it's trying to keep one
level so
you know these kind of shots the
the heli pilots have to be as good as
the dp in a way and usually they're a
team
so they work together a lot i'm sure
peter jackson had resources to to have
like a very very good aerial dp and a
very very good heli pilot so
very cool shot just kind of wrapping
around and then
they kind of pull back
that's probably the hardest shot in
there shooting in the mountains is in
particular is is very difficult
for aerials um because the mountains
just topographically are obviously like
very mountainous so that means that
there's a lot of air moving
especially
in the evening and
in the mornings when there's like a
differential between
the
air temperatures so that means there's
uplifts or down drafts those happen to
be the best time to shoot in the
mountains for light there could be a ton
of turbulence i mean these gyro
stabilized cameras are amazing they have
like 16 gyros in it so even when the
helicopter is kind of bouncing around
but you know if you're trying to do a
really steady move in the mountains and
you're like moving over a ridge
that then has like huge updraft like
it's complicated there's there's a lot
of things that you have to think about
when you're when you're when you're
filming aerials in the mountains and
it's dangerous and you need really
high-powered helicopters probably like a
b3 which just means like a type of
helicopter that's got
a lot of power because the air is
thinner at altitude and
there's a lot less lift
for the helicopters sometimes when we
fly aerial shots in the mountains we
really trim down the crew take strip
down the helicopter make sure most of
the weight is just
for the dp that pilot maybe the aerial
director and then the
big gyro stabilized system camera system
prepping for something like this this is
it'll probably start on a storyboard and
then the dp and the director and then
the heli pilot are all probably sitting
down with the a.d and everybody else but
principally talking about like what are
they trying to achieve in this shot then
how are they going to achieve the shot
and oftentimes
you know when we have something like
that's this complicated
we'll focus on like okay this is what we
want to achieve this is how we're going
to do it we're going to do a safety shot
which is like kind of our most kind of
conservative way to shoot this shot and
until you get that kind of safety shot
in the can
um you're not trying like all kinds of
other stuff but if you feel really good
about
getting you know i think we have that
shot and then you've got a little bit
more budget or time in the moment
because you know if it's like an
insane sunset
or like in this case
like crazy cloud scenario which
might or might not be cg once you've got
your safety shot and you feel like
you've nailed that then you can move on
to like
trying a few other
shots that you might have in mind or the
dp really wanted but didn't want to risk
you know blowing the shot point break
this is a
shot at chopu which is a
very notoriously
huge and gnarly uh gnarly wave i
remember hearing a few friends who were
on this production as as the surfers or
running safety on this thing
when point break was being made a lot of
people
i guess in my sphere worked on it this
is big you know kind of action adventure
sports movie so
a lot of people in the industry got the
call and to come shoot on this project
they brought in
kind of
the best of the best who shoot each of
these individual sports which is
definitely a smart idea because a
this is what they shoot they know the
angles they know
all the different ways it's been shot
what are options and what are not
options because sometimes the director
might come in and be like so i want this
shot and as a dp you you really try to
to get that shot but you know there are
limitations to places like this or
activities like this in terms of how you
can shoot but you're always trying to
push
you know what's a new angle that's never
been shot before and and what what would
it take to get that shot and then you
try to figure it out when you bring in a
uh someone who does shoot this stuff it
it serves multiple purposes again
because they know all the angles they've
shot at chopu
a ton of times a ton of seasons they
know when the rights you know they're
tracking the swells they know when it's
going to be huge
they know what seasons there's all kinds
of things that are tied into shooting
you know at a place like this because it
has to be perfect conditions which is
challenging you know it's like you can't
just
make this thing happen and have the wave
breaking as big as it is right there you
can keep it
authentic and and hopefully they're also
consulting on like this is what they do
this is how they would be on the boat
this is what they would wear this is how
they would talk this is you know these
are the things that they should be
talking about if they're
on the boat i'm sure they have all kinds
of consultants not just you know the dp
talking about it but the you know having
someone who shoots this sport this
lifestyle this place
uh has huge advantages
lawrence of arabia
it's incredible to see
you know how much space you're given in
this shot it's quiet
there's only a few words spoken
but
you know there's so much tension that
happens just in the way that they shoot
it there's all the suspense in what this
figure is and who that figure is coming
through the the mirage there it's
interesting because the like in the
sahara and in desert landscapes like
this the the landscape is
really uniform this happens up in the um
in in
like huge snowy places like and plateaus
on like in tibet as well everything is
so uniform
in color
you know it's sky
and
sand
or sky and snow so when there's any
thing that breaks that up your eye is
drawn to it and in this case
you have this like perfectly framed
figure
all clad in black breaking up this like
very desolate landscape
and so
you know your eyes immediately drawn to
this thing and you can't tell what it is
the character can't tell what it is but
it's coming towards you and
seems like imminent danger shooting in
the desert
has its challenges too you know one of
the things that
has gotten me and and
um
happens i'm sure on productions instead
of dealing with rain and moisture and
like lenses fogging up
you're dealing with
this really fine dust particles that get
into all the mechanics of the
of these lenses and they somehow
infiltrate everything managing sand is
one issue and you get these sandstorms
uh like in the sahara the the harmon
winds come in and it's just you can't
really see and it blows this
ultra ultra fine dust
sand
and it penetrates everything like these
zippers break because you can't even so
there's there's challenges there
and then the heat
is
can be debilitating as well the beach
[Music]
[Music]
in general we're
small crews um and pretty low profile
when we're especially in like remote
locations when we're shooting bigger
commercial shoots or shoots where you
have like 50 to 100 or
you know you do
have to think about
you know
how you're going to impact an area
particularly if it's in the wilderness
so you know i think there's just like
basic principles of like leave no trace
i'm sure that now there's a lot of
restrictions and guidelines about
coming into a place like this but when
you're shooting in countries where
there's there's fewer regulations you
kind of have to take it upon yourself to
kind of you know
mitigate your impact and
kind of carry that ethos of leave no
trace and and making sure that
you know you're leaving an area
the same or better than you found it
thanks so much for watching these clips
with me hopefully you learned something
and until next time